We've thought about that with like what we decide to show and not show after
mass shootings here.
Yeah.
You know,
like,
um,
I was in Pittsburgh like right after and I was,
because I knew the rabbi who was doing some of the cleanup and because of
religious reasons,
your Bat Mitzvah was there.
That is so crazy.
And Yeah,
my dad knew six of the people who were murdered.
And um,
but like it was really crazy to me how locked down,
it wasn't like you couldn't take it.
I was there with a photographer and you couldn't take any pictures at all of
anything,
you know?
And there's a real lockdown on showing people because who don't want to terrify
people,
but I've wondered would it prick people's consciousness about the reality of
what gun violence looks like?
You know,
like the carnage,
like the people that I know that Saad said it looked like a war zone.
And would that change public policy and would that be a positive thing or would
we just become numb to it?
Like we become numb to everything else?
I don't know.
That's a very good question.
I never in favor of suppressing inflammation,
even horrific information.
Um,
I was a big critic of that during the Bush administration when they passed
laws on whether or not you're allowed to show,
uh,
actual coffins,
just coffins.
You weren't allowed to show coffins being flown back.
I felt like that was,
that's a disgrace.
That's it.
I mean,
you should,
if you,
if we're going to consider whether or not we want our team,
yes,
we should be able to understand the real consequences.
And one of the best ways is to not just get information in terms of text.
Text is very difficult for you to conceptualize,
but when you would,
seeing American flags covering coffins and you're seeing hundreds of them and
you realize these are your neighbors these year and your neighbor's children's,
this is,
this is people that you,
you know,
and they're dying over there and you can't really,
you can't wrap your head around why they're doing it and whether or not it's
right,
whether or not we should have been there.
And then whether or not they're actually were weapons of mass destruction in
Iraq,
whether or not we're in the business of nation building,
whether or not Ron Paul is right,
whether or not other people are right.
Well who's right,
like the only way we're really going to get a clear picture is to see a picture.
To have an actual,
yeah.
Well that,
that's why I've thought about this a lot because right now I think in most
Americans' minds it's like the shooting happens,
then it becomes a Hashtag,
then it becomes a tee shirt.
Then it becomes a memorial thing,
a memorial concert.
I mean it's like actually sickening like the,
the choreography of it and I think what's lost is what it looks like and this
rabbi in Pittsburgh who's really amazing,
describe to me what he saw and I'll never forget just the description of what he
told me and I wondered,
I've a lot in the wake of that and I'll think about it with the next shooting
happens,
would that have made a difference at all in terms of waking people up?
What's fucked up as you said,
when the next shooting happens.
Well we know it will happen.
Yeah,
we know it will happen.
Yeah.
Um,
yeah.
Why?
Because,
because there are a lot of guns in this country and people have access to those
guns who are not only mentally unwell.
Sometimes they're just evil and they want to kill people and they want to be
fame.
I mean for a million reasons,
but the fact that we are living in a culture that seems to worship people's
freedom to own those weapons more than human life seems crazy to me.
It really does.
I get what you're saying.
The argument against that would be this,
look,
the real crazies believe that these things are happening and that they're
happening because of the fact that government wants to take away our guns.
This is the real crazies.
Explain that.
I'm not sure I followed that.
They are making these people do these things.
The government that the worst,
worst aspects of our society,
whatever,
you know,
fill in the blank with whatever left wing conspiracy that you know,
whatever person,
whatever boogeyman,
George Soros Boogie man,
is that the whatever boogeyman or book or cabal of Boogie people that they are
somehow or another either using like Manchurian candidate type influence,
whatever the fuck they're doing,
they're getting people to do this and then even creating false flags where these
things didn't happen so they can take away guns.
This is the,
I mean look,
this is exactly what it is.
Dot.
It is,
you're right.
it is.
It is dumb,
but it's real.
It's real.
In terms of the influence that it has that people actually do believe that there
are these false flag events that they're designing to to get your guns,
that people are training people to go out and kill a bunch of people so that
they can take away your guns.
So it makes them more rabid about their support of the second amendment and
they,
they feel like they're being attacked on all sides.
Have you lived very shimmer on here recently?
Last week they can see the mindset of the conspiracy thinker is totally
fascinating to me.
It is.
A West is actually just as good or even better.
He runs Medibank.
He's a fascinating guy.
I used to do this show,
I did the show for awhile on the Scifi.
I called Joe Rogan questions,
everything.
And one of the things that we went into was a why people believe in chem trails,
why people believe that the heat of jet engines,
which causes these artificial clouds when it interacts with condensation in the
atmosphere and creates,
creates artificial clouds.
You see trails.
Some people believe that these are,
that someone spraying something and that this weather control from these
commercial jets that they're there,
you know,
somehow then there's this gigantic conspiracy of all these people involved and
that this is in some way,
uh,
they're,
they're either doing weather control or the controlling us or mind control.
It depends on who you ask.
And,
but Mick had a really interesting way of discussing it.
And one of the things that he said is this is like the training wheels for
conspiracy theory because you see it in the sky,
like,
look,
there it is.
I don't remember that you want these photographs from world war two where you
can see from the 1940s you could see contrails in the sky that look just like
the ones up here.
But people will say,
I don't remember those when we were kids.
And they little,
yeah,
I don't.
And then it starts fueling this paranoid idea that there's this program going
on.
And then there are real programs that the government is considering to combat
global warming.
Where they talked about this in the,
in the 70s and the 80s they talked about,
um,
reflective particles in the atmosphere.
I think there were,
when they were concerned that the ozone layer was beat McManamon was the 80s a
pro probably later than that.
But even more recently,
they've talked about suspending reflective particles in the atmosphere to
protect it.
But it'd be very different.
But why do people believe conspiracy theories?
What is it in the nature of certain people that that I'm just so fascinated by
it.
That's a good question.
That's what I was going to ask you.
Oh,
what do you,
when you see it from the outside,
when you see something like a,
like the most horrific ones like sandy hook,
like sandy hook being a false flag,
what would be the motivation for someone saying that?
What would be the motivation?
The only thing I can,
I mean the most plausible I guess would be
okay
capturing an audience.
Like getting people to believe in you is some sear behind the veil.
Yeah,
but that's only the people that are projecting this in terms of in the meeting
I'm talking about like an Alex Jones.
Like why does he say that?
My question is why do other people think it?
Why do they look for it?
Not,
not a person who's profiting?
I think that's,
I think the reason people look to conspiracy theories is that the world is
okay,
deeply chaotic and seems to lack a logic and people are desperate for a system
of understanding the world.
And conspiracy theories often seem to like offer a very,
very,
actually like an incredibly simplistic explanation,
which is there's this secret fee.
Like there's always a secret thing that is a plan that the public doesn't know
about general you'll thing is that no one really is at the wheel.
Yeah.
The real thing is that,
I mean,
haven't we learned that from the Trump presidency?
Right?
Like institutions are just made up of people like they can fall apart if the
people that take them over are irresponsible,
crazy,
Venal,
narcissistic.
Everything that we're seeing in Trump administration will also like people.
But isn't that kind of,
it's weirdly,
I mean it's both terrifying but also comforting.
I think like if it's people,
if it's just people,
people can also change it.
Right,
okay.
It's not like there's a secret hand that we need to get to.
Yeah.
Just,
okay.
What's the solution?
Elect better people.
Do you think the hopeful part,
I think
that this,
such as it is,
this constant conflict,
this social conflict that we're involved in right now,
the woke left and the alt right and all this jazz,
that there's the,
the,
the boiling of it right now will eventually boil down to something more
rational.
Because if it seems like if you,
if you read Steven Pinker's work and people that study violence and in danger
and society over the course of history that we're,
we're certainly on an upward trend,
even though when the data shows know all the data shows that no one's denying
that there are some awful aspects to our culture today in society and Crime and
violence and,
and fill in the blank and all disparity.
And yes,
all those things exist,
but there's more understanding of that is more awareness of that.
And there's certainly a safer,
safer world today than was,
you know,
a hundred,
200 years ago in terms of like,
you're your own existence.